a dazzling display of opulence and
fantasy a Dutch designer Ronald Fanta
camps Paris couture show models will
sculptural gowns for an elegant take on
80s glamour but van de Kamp's fashion
isn't only a lesson in creativity but
also in sustainability all his clothes
are made from recycled vintage or
repurposed fabrics fake fur is one of
the worst things for the environment so
for me this is the this is the answer to
fake fur because this is made with all
leftovers from old collections the coat
was made by an organization helping
women in Morocco part of van de Kamp's
conviction that fashion must be
responsible he launched his sustainable
Couture label five years ago we're
leading the way to make sustainability
sexy and sustainability the new normal
because that's what it needs to be I
think the bigger brands should you know
reduce their productions and make less
clothes and concentrate on making
beautiful clothes rather than all these
clothes that nobody needs the fashion
industry is one of the world's biggest
polluters high-end labels influence
mass-market brands and consumers many
concede it's time for change after 50
years in the business French designer
Jean Paul Gautier retired with a show
with an anti waste message don't burn
the clothes and recycle them well some
of the world's most prestigious fashion
houses are based in Paris and most say
that they're trying to become more
environmentally friendly but campaigners
say the sustainability is increasingly
used as an on-trend marketing tool
rather than a real plan of action
Barbara one year is an expert in
sustainable luxury she says customers
are helping to accelerate change because
Omotesando present through consumers are
increasingly aware and want to be more
responsible socially and environmentally
so in the last few years they've
realized that one way to act is to buy
differently this former fire station in
the city will soon become Europe's
biggest sustainable fashion hub called
like
Kazaam bringing together designers and
experts helping them to create
responsibly they don't have the choice
because now we know the the nature is
suffering we cannot do exactly what
we've done before we need to change
something changing a multibillion-dollar
industry is a challenge but in an
environment driven by trends where and
responsibly made clothes may become the
ultimate fashion statement
Natasha butler al Jazeera Paris